(crowd clapping) Oh, miss Harlow.
Oh, my goodness.
Thank you for having me.
Oh, I'm so very honored and excited to meet you.
So nice to meet you as well.
Okay.
Let's go right to your childhood Winnie.
Okay, let's start from the beginning.
Let's start from the beginning.
Okay, when you were four you were diagnosed
with an auto-immune condition, vitiligo.
And what was your life like when you were a kid?
What was your family like?
What were your feelings?
Who were you at four years old?
At four years old, I was a really happy child.
And I think that's because my family was
so loving and so supporting.
And so, they had such a will to make sure that I felt normal
and felt like my differences were
a very important part of who I was.
When I did first get vitiligo my mom was, she was worried,
you know, it was something that she hadn't heard of before.
So I remember her bringing me over to my grandmother
and my aunt and lifting up the back of my shirt
and being like, look, there's a new spot on her back.
And my grandmother was like, you can't do that to her
because she's going to feel like her differences
are something that's negative and that's not right.
She has to grow up knowing that all the things
that make her her are valid and are beautiful.
And that's how you make her feel important.
Well, I love hearing that too, because I,
as a parent am learning on the job,
I think we probably all are.
And what a blessing
that your grandmother had such awesome wisdom for your mom.
For sure, it's so important I think today,
especially with social media and so many outlets for kids to
go to, to learn or watch things,
I think we forget that the most important place
for children to learn is at home.
What parents teach their kids
and enforce in their kids is so important.
Well, you've been a real force on social media.
And ironically, I heard you were sort of, you know,
tentative to put yourself out there at first.
And now you're one of the world's biggest supermodels.
How does it go from like tentative putting toe in
the water to being one of the most famous beauties
on planet earth?
Stop. (laughing)
It's true.
Thank you, I appreciate it.
I think it was just because it was something that was new
and anything that's new is kind of scary.
But when I realized that people were so excited
about me putting myself out there and the way I felt
about myself, and how I felt like I was beautiful
and I wasn't going
to let someone else's opinions get me down and
that encourage others to do the same,
I was like, you know what, if it's inspiring
for other people, let me continue.
Let me just be out there
because everyone goes through something.
Everyone is different which is
what makes us all at the same.
So, I have this thing where like,
people always wanna be normal, but like,
what is normal?
There's this idea of what normal is, but everyone's normal.
You have freckles, that's normal.
You have brown hair, that's normal.
You have green eyes, that's normal.
You have brown eyes, that's normal.
All these things are normal.
I mean, do you wanna have kids?
Because I think you should be basically a parent to us all.
(laughing)
I do want kids, but not right now. (laughing)
I mean, I think that when you talk
about how we all have this shared common experience,
to hear you talking about that, I think I just,
I look forward to my daughters, you know, learning
and experiencing life through your eyes and your wisdom,
and your words because I think they're very calming
and healing, and yet really inspiring and energizing
at the same time
Thank you.
I think that's because I don't take myself too seriously
and I understand that I'm a human like,
I always say, I don't believe in role models.
I don't believe in putting anyone on a pedestal to say,
this is who I should be like,
but I do believe in pulling inspiration from everyone.
No, one's perfect.
People are going to make mistakes.
I make mistakes all the time.
And while I love that people pull inspiration for me,
I wouldn't wanna be anyone's like, role model
or put up on a pedestal because I know I'm only human.
I don't know Winnie,
I'm getting super hero vibes.(laughing)
I'm hearing superhero wisdom and--
Even superheroes have their kryptonite.
Yes, they absolutely do.
In fact, superheroes are incredibly flawed.
I'm trying to think inside, like what my kryptonite is.
Do you have a kryptonite?
My kryptonite is maybe like, I'm from the hood
so sometimes I just like to get like real street with it
and just say, what's real and what's on my mind.
Sometimes I need a little filter sometimes.
So yeah, not having a filter sometimes is my kryptonite.
I like your kryptonite, I'm into your kryptonite.
I feel like I want, like, I want more
of your street no filter.
I'm already rocking the body language of it
and I'd like to hear what comes out.
I'm not going to lie, maybe we can throw down sometime
because I'm like, oh, I want in, I want some of like,
Winnie's no filter.
Yeah, come to a party with me and we'll vibe out.
Wow, Winnie you are making me feel alive again.
(laughing)
I used to go to parties.
For sure.
Winnie,
will you please take me to a party?
I have been in my mom mode,
100%
For so long, like--
Listen, and then When I finally have kids,
then you can help me out there as well
cause I know I'm gonna need tons of help.
Yes, I can.
And I too will always be encouraging
for us to not take ourselves too seriously,
for us to promote strength
and humor and humanity.
Yes.
(upbeat music)